well i always say say everything with a
smile
you'll get away with murder if you're
charming or with a positive attitude i
think
two different people can do almost the
same kind of material but one is seen as
dirtier than the other
and i think a lot of the times it it is
on the delivery
or the your demeanor on stage or maybe
how you're dressed i think it just
depends on like
how you say it all right
hot breath averse welcome back to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
this is our live q and a series
happening exclusively in our facebook
group so if you're listening to this
later on our podcast or watching this on
our youtube
go into the description click join the
facebook group to get involved in more q
and a's and much more
with comics from around the world and
today's
guest i've been a huge fan of for years
and it's so exciting she is finally
releasing her debut album voluptuous boy
which makes me laugh just thinking it
but please welcome to the hot breath the
verse
the one and only sarah tolemosh ladies
and gentlemen give it up for sarah
everyone
having me absolutely thank you for doing
this oh my gosh
so yeah let's uh let's make sure we on
i mean we are on but i want to get into
it i did um
i made a cool overlay for this for our
interview and i wanted to see
oh really it's a it's all fancy paintsy
and i think it works oh cool we're just
upgrading
i don't even know what it is it's an
overlay
i stream using a program called ecam
where you can um you can add like
overlay
kind of instead of zoom where we're just
seeing black
it's like a white border with the show
logo and all that
oh i gotta do that i keep wondering how
all these people are doing it
and then i never ask so it's good to
know
yeah this this is donald way i've been
able to find
um but i think you can do it within zoom
if you pay like the top
rate or whatever but wow i don't know
it's like i haven't been on stage since
march so i'm like where can i spend my
creativity
you know so it's been doing this
yeah i wish i invested into in zoom
uh i know they must be killing it
what if what have you been doing uh
because i've see you've done you
you're doing shows more recently it
seems like what have you been doing
um to like stay creative to stay sharp
like
what are you kind of doing to spend your
time right now
um well i like making videos
so i do that sketches and then uh or
like short
film stuff and then i got into tick tock
and then i would try out jokes on tick
tock and that was effective
so i could kind of open mic it on there
oh
could gain traction on stage so it was
good
um and now they're taking it away from
us apparently so i'm kind of bummed
about it
will you see it translate like if it
works on tick tock does it actually
translate when you've tried it on stage
yeah it's i mean it's like i treat it
like twitter and that's how i
would try out jokes anyway is like i
would tweet something
a thought and then if it got a lot of
traction then i was like oh maybe
there's something here and then i just
try it on stage and then generally
most of the time it works but sometimes
it's too
zeitgeisty that it would only work for
about five minutes and then everybody's
moved on and there's no point to like
do it on stage and then explain
something that was so
small right six months ago
yeah i love hearing a grown-up as a as a
grown
woman in your 40s you're like i'm trying
this tick-tock thing you know
all the kids there's a lot of us on
there oh i'm seeing all the comedians
it's just funny to see like grown-ups
but yeah i was just talking to john reap
and he's like yeah i've been on
tick-tock dancing with my mom
i was like all right internet okay
yeah um their algorithm seems to be a
little bit more democratic
than um instagrams
yeah that seems to be the big draw it's
like you can make you can have a rags to
riches story on tick tock
more than you can on instagram
well how long have you been doing comedy
um probably close to 20 years but i
would say
um you know on a more serious level
probably the last 10 or 12.
wow okay yeah because you started in
houston correct
yeah and it was just different meaning
like
i don't know you you think you're doing
it by going on stage
once a week with the showcase show every
few months or so and then you're like oh
i'm doing it but then when you move to
new york you're like you're not really
you're not really doing it until you get
to like new york
yeah when you're like actually working
on it going out every night
um building a set where you know
if you're not getting a lot of stage
time i think it's hard to build a set
yeah and i didn't realize 20 20 years
but you've been doing it seriously for
like this is just now your debut album
you've made several late night
appearances and things like that but
what made you
feel like you were ready to release an
album
um well i had been probably having
like my 45 minutes to 55 that i really
liked for a while
and then um i never really thought about
it because i always thought about it
more in the aspect of like well who's
going to buy it
because i can't eat you know it's hard
to get seats filled right now
where i'm at so that's that's where i
was at with thinking about it but then
800 pound gorilla came to me and was
like hey would be interested in doing an
album
and then i was like well this is as good
as time as any
i've been headlining a little bit for a
while i feel comfortable at least
attempting to get it on to record it
and then um yeah i was like why not
and then after i did it then i was like
i should have just been doing this the
whole time
so now i regret not working on a longer
set
earlier what what made you
think oh i should have been doing it
earlier on like how long into your
career do you think
it's good for a comic to even like
pursue that
i think as soon as you have like 45
minutes
that you've been working on for at least
six months to a year
um that you feel like is consistent
um in front of a large group of people
uh
i think that's a good time to work on it
and the reason why i kind of regret not
doing it working on an album more often
is that
i actually really enjoyed the process
and there was something about having an
end goal and i think i would have
created more hours
throughout my career and it it's an
easy diy for yourself like you can just
create your own album and getting it on
itunes and getting it on serious like
you don't need a record label for that
that um that's a good way to have people
share your stuff and then get
you know a larger audience to know who
you are and maybe that
can get them to come to your shows so it
was just like an
enjoyable process i thought and what was
that
process like uh how many times did you
run this set how close up to the
recording date were you still
tinkering with the set um
so these are jokes that i probably been
doing for the last five years on the
road
and um there's still some stuff that i
didn't feel like doing because it felt
dated to me so i
didn't put it on the album but i think i
started
really figuring out my set list around
in october or november hilarities in
cleveland
had offered me to do a headlining gig
um i was coming in with joe my husband
to feature that week and they said why
don't you come in a day early in
headline
so that was really great because i could
run it in front of a club audience
and that's when i started and then i
started listening to it and then i set
up a week at the creek
at the creek in the cave in long island
city and uh
that one nobody nobody came but i just
ran it anyway
like it's like six o'clock it's not like
a place that
a lot of people go to to see comedy um
it's just like a great workout room but
just running it and figuring out my
order and i still could kind of
determine
what i thought had was strong enough and
what wasn't
and i was still tweaking it like days
prior and i still feel like even when
things are done i'm always thinking of
like how
i was like oh i probably that joke
probably i could add on more
to it like things never feel like
they're ever done to me
um and so i
yeah i had so i figured out my set list
and i just ran it over and over again
because i don't have i don't get to
headline that often because the clubs
because i don't bring in people
so you have to figure out other ways to
um
run a set like i don't suggest
just doing 45 minutes of recording if
you've never
run 45 minutes before i mean i think
that's
kind of insane but that's just me but
even if you like
maybe you're at a feature level but you
have 45 minutes you almost
maybe for a feature weekend you record
every single set
and maybe can piece it together that way
yeah you can and you should but like
i don't know things are it's just
different like i i feel like
for the longest time i was doing 15
minutes and that felt really good and i
felt really comfortable with that and
then
i always when i started doing 30 minutes
i felt like when i was hitting the 20
minute mark
you realize the crowd if you're just
like telling jokes with no performance
aspect to it
you realize the crowd kind of gets maybe
a little
bored with you so you have to inc you
have to figure out other ways to be
captivating and i feel like
walking around the stage instead of
staying in one spot inflicting in your
voice
and i feel like you only do that you
work your rhythm of your long sets by
running it over and over again
yeah i for me personally i think it's
harder to piece it together
trunk by chunk i rather like if i was
going to shoot a special
i'd like to know that i was running that
set almost every weekend for at least a
good six months
yeah and that is good to know of you
saying it's like have a 45 minute set
but then work it out for six months to a
year and then
record it it's like the refining process
yeah because it's just i don't know it's
just different to have an
audience sit there be captivated with
you for 45 minutes it's quite different
than just doing 15 minutes
yeah it's so much more rewarding though
because like you feel like you
you're building there's like a rapport
in a relationship it's
i just uh i've i've been doing comedy
over 10 years and i just
really started doing more headlining
stuff like last year
and then like um covet happens but uh
is a completely completely different
like game
when you when you have 45 minutes you're
at first like can i even
talk for 45 minutes and then the more
you do it the more comfortable you get
with it but
it was like starting over which is
exciting yeah it's a mental game
i feel like it reminds me of running
sometimes you want to quit when you're
20 minutes in and you're like no you got
to keep
you got to sustain this like level of
entertainment
it's hard yeah but that's what keeps it
keeps it invigorating though too yeah
always staying out of your comfort zone
i feel like is
has has keeps keeps your comedy sharp
and exciting whether if you've been
doing the same open mic
in a smaller scene if you've been doing
the same open mic every week like switch
it up like
start your own show or go to a different
show like
staying out of the ruts i think really
help keep it fresh
yeah like def i try to make a rule like
every time i go up i at least try one
new thing
if it's not an important set um but yeah
that way you constantly are like working
or building off of it and when you when
you're developing material like what is
your
writing process because even just like a
word choice
of you you talking about avocados and
using this word
hatch it's i just love word choice and
like the specificity between like a
laugh and a lull can be that one word
and you just
using hatch i was like oh she like gets
into the nitty-gritty
of like word choice and really how you
can paint a picture with a single word
so like what is your writing process in
developing a tight bit
um well i definitely probably start off
with twitter so it's an
idea and it usually feels like a topic
sentence
and of a paragraph and so
i generally go off of a feeling that i
have
so like i'll just for example the
avocado joke like i don't know i just
had i remember one night i'm like
i the whole time i was walking to my
show in my mind i was stressed that i
was like i have three avocados at
home that are like
are about to expire and i really like i
don't want to throw them away and i keep
wasting food like that and then i was
making me laugh that it was like
taking up so much mental real estate in
my mind and then i thought it would be
funny if i just canceled
shows so i could just stay at home and
make sure i could eat my
avocado said then it felt like they look
like eggs
and then they it kind of like an
incubation
and so i thought of the word hatch and
yeah and i actually really like enjoy
doing
stuff that way and that's that's how it
started so it started off as a tweet and
then when i went on stage
you i end up like tagging on stage so i
do a lot of my writing
as i go up on stage because sometimes
when the audience gives you feedback
then it feels good you want to keep
writing that wave and
and then i'll talk that bit until it i
kill it
and then i know where to stop oh i love
are you so are you thinking through when
you think okay
i have three avocados at home oh no i
better get back oh this is funny that
i'm even thinking this and then are you
like
avocados avocados well they look like
eggs
maybe they hatch like does it come
together did it come together all as
you're walking to the show
um yeah or just like you know you just
as you say something on stage it's just
like
if you're in a good mood and you're
feeling really funny that night and the
crowd is really responsive to you
it puts me in that zone of like just
tagging
and being thinking of my mind seems to
get more relaxed
and then it kind of comes to you while
you're on stage and then
you know in a situation like that i you
call it mapping
what what does this feel like to you and
then you use other elements from that
comparison
and see if it works with what you're
talking about
can you go into mapping more yeah
i guess it's a term that you use like i
learned it in
sketch writing and it's like taking
one incident and being like this is a
very similar feeling to this other
incident i'm trying i can't think of an
example right now which is so
infuriating
let me see if i have um i guess one
example i remember one time um
you know how girls always have the
dilemma of um
like am i gonna cut my bangs or i'm
going to cut my
like it's a constant thing in our life
of cutting our bangs
and i was just thinking how like it just
seems like
a really weird like a small problem but
it feels like a big problem to us
that so i wrote a sketch of us in a like
log cabin and we're a poor family and
then i mapped it over that
and the problems that you would have in
a depression
or in a dust bowl and then i did it
with cutting bangs so i i put the bangs
in that scenario and i think that would
be what you would consider
mapping oh and then maybe like common
phrases from the dust bowl
you may just apply to cutting bangs
yeah that it works it works that way
like i had a whole monologue of my great
the grandmother going through her
generations of cutting bangs and stuff
like that that's what they did
so and if it like people see it better
or like one time i wear i felt like i
was always working on my printer and i
was like this is like working on some
this equivalent of working on your car
but it's not as cool so then i
you write that way so that's just like
one technique
that i use to like expand a bit
it works in sketch that's where i got it
do you have any other techniques you
could uh
share with us uh
that's the only one i can think of i'm
sure as i talk more along i'll probably
like
um remember comparisons are always good
i try not to use
um what is it that's like if this was
like this
because i feel like that's a very
obvious way to state something but if
you use it in a hyperbole
hyperbolically i don't know how you
pronounce it um
i think people will know what you're
getting at without having to state it
and it feels more effective that way
oh if it's almost like more
conversational or comes off more natural
yeah like treating it treating a
lightweight
subject as if it had it's a very serious
death like a like a traumatic experience
i think is always kind of like a funny
way of treating things
yeah that is a really intriguing
contrast i'm going to start looking
for more in my own material and my own
ideas
of you even like the avocado one
about the steaks heightened so much i'm
actually gonna cancel shows for this and
it's almost like the bigger the contrast
maybe the more
comedy potential yeah i
i guess it's just kind of like uh
i don't know i don't even know how to
explain it but like
i don't know i feel like sometimes um
like if you're a really dirty comic
i feel like it's good to dress really
nice like
i like the ying and the yang it's a very
nice
balance and i think people like it and
it's a way to soften
things and get and you can get away with
a lot more
oh yeah this is uh patrick is saying the
avocado joke and call back is great
um and hearing your thought process is
very helpful
very nice oh cool yeah people are saying
they loving the avocado bit
uh bob jorgensen said
he follows you on twitter and he's
crying
oh he said i just followed sarah on
twitter four minutes ago and i'm crying
laughing at the pin
tweet um oh that one
that one's probably funny to me now
because it's so out of context that if
people saw that as my first tweet they'd
be like what the is she talking
about
it's someone's getting roasted for not
um
listening to your album yet he's like
wait where's the avocado bit and now
people are roasting him for not knowing
your avocado bit
oh don't worry dude you you just go on
the first the first track and you'll be
there and you don't have to dig deep for
it
so it's so good like how did you um how
did you decide the order
for your set well
that one for the order of my set it's
weird because
when i was running it at the creek and i
thought about it
i split it up into two 25 minute
chunks or two 20 to 25 minute chunks
um because it's easier for me to
memorize i have a really hard time
memorizing stuff i don't it's like a
mental block for me so
i find it yucky i don't like doing it so
i don't
attempt and the only way that i can do
it is if i keep doing things over and
over again where it becomes a muscle
memory but the
idea of actively memorizing something is
so awful
um so i broke it down into two
20 25 minute chunks and then i i could
remember it that way so i could
flip them around and i would do that as
as i was running sets in the city which
would help me memorize
knowing that i didn't have to have them
in that exact order but if i knew it
then it would make me feel comfortable
on stage so
i was starting off with my second half
as my first half
and then i realized i felt like it might
be it had a lot more weirder
and dirtier like vulgar stuff maybe or
sex stuff
and i always think and just as watching
stand up throughout the times everybody
usually puts their dirtier or weirder
stuff towards the end
because you want the audience especially
for an album and somebody doesn't know
you that well
i think it's good to have them trust you
and kind of know what your voice is
before you start
doing stuff like that so they know that
you're not
serious and that you're only making fun
of everything and you don't
like for me i didn't have i wanted
you to not really know what my strong
opinion is
like irreverent so i think that's why i
put the cleaner stuff
up front and then i went with the um uh
the dirtier stuff and the weirder stuff
towards the end
yeah it's almost like you get them on
your side and then they'll go wherever
you want to go but if you
opened with your closer that would set a
completely different
um expectation for this turn it off
and then also from there it's like hard
to follow your observational bits when
you've like
talked about your genitals or whatever
you know what i mean
like i'll notice that when i have to
follow a certain comics on stage
if they're like if they're particularly
um vulgar which is fine because i'm
vulgar too but like
to follow that in a different energy and
then you're going up there talking about
your printer or avocados then the crowd
is like
what yeah like it takes a while to reset
and so it just makes it very difficult
so i'm like why would i set myself up
for failure
in my own set so i'd i decided with that
to start with the cleaner stuff up front
and the more relatable broader
topics and did you have like um
a set list and are your set lists um
like pen to paper are you in your phone
are they keywords are they phrases how
do you do that
um my set list i keep i so i have like
two notebooks i have a notebook that i
just kind of free write in
um and then i have my set list that i
actually use probably more often than my
actual joke book
and it's just um all that my sets that
i'm working with
and um i usually flip back sometimes i
forget a joke
i accidentally drop one as time goes by
and then i get to flip through my set
list and be like oh yeah i
forgot about that i should bring that
back here or that goes better with this
bit now
so yeah i just i write the same
even when i know i already have my set
list memorized i write it because it's
like
a nervous tick before show it makes me
feel better to at least
feel like i'm in that mindset to like go
up on stage if i write my set list
yeah i do every every show i'm i'm
making a set list
like even if i know the jokes it yeah it
just keeps me in that mode of like
i'm not here just killing time i'm here
working on
something yeah you you gotta go up with
a little bit of a plan or something to
fall back on i mean you can go up on the
stage and like you know start doing
crowd work
but like once they start getting settled
you can go as long as you know what
you're doing
it kind of makes me feel comfortable
yeah and this is uh stefan
saying he loves the new album and your
bit about
people crying in public is hilarious oh
yeah
that's a new york thing oh there's so
many good ones
um this one actually and speaking of
your bits this one comes from liam
harvey
who says hi sarah love your album wanted
to know the process behind creating the
great umbel
umbrella bit thank you oh
yeah that's another one kind of like it
falls in the same mindset of
um avocados i think
because i was i i saw the forecast for
the day
and it said it was going to rain and
then so a lot of times in new york
once you leave your apartment you're
gone for 16 hours
so i had i didn't rain i was carrying
this umbrella with me
all day long and i kept forgetting it at
places
and then um i found it to be a burden
because it took away one of my hands so
it was hard to carry a coffee and all
this
and then that was another one where
you're like oh my god
if i can't even handle this and i find
this so not
fun and unenjoyable i don't know how i'm
gonna handle having a child
and so that's how that bit came along
as well so it that's another one that i
was like this is taking up so much
mental real estate for an umbrella
um like i cannot believe i'm thinking
about this stupid object as much as i am
right now
that's so great well one i yeah i loved
that bit i like
cackled out loud as i was driving um
listening to that just making that
connection you know
um something seemingly so mundane and
then something seemingly like life or
death
as like a child you know so it is it
seems like you're very
how do you do it you're skilled at like
sorry to cut you off there
um you're you're very like skilled at
like
listening to your sense of humor almost
it seems like you're
you're honed in on if something is
singing to you like a spidey sense
almost
you're you know you're on to something
like that sense of humor you're tapped
into it feels like
yeah i think and that's for anybody
and that i feel like this is how you
probably develop your own voice
is like i don't a lot of times i don't
really
go for the joke i'm not thinking of a
joke in my head i think what is best to
go on
is like go off of a feeling and you're
like why is this bothering me why do i
find this strange
what is about this thing that is so
weird or like
um like annoying you because you're like
it's so small or stupid
and then from there like sometimes just
the obsessiveness of thinking about
something you're like obviously
this is something very passionate to me
right now and i should probably
um think about why it's in my mind and
then i think that's where
i get the joke as i figure out how to
write for myself that way
and i think that's a great way of making
sure that
no one takes your joke because it only
works for you
i think when you do stuff like that it's
harder for joke stealing i think
yeah it's like that's the common phrase
i've heard is like no one can steal
you yeah well it's like a lot of times
people get like um
self-conscious about talking about a
subject matter that's probably been
talked about on stage ad nauseam but i
always say
if it's something that feels really
personal to you and it's like in a
specific thing that happened you with
this thing then i say go for it and it
makes it
see it makes that joke stand out
different than what everybody else is
doing and it's very like
to that person's voice so i say keep
don't worry about like if it's being
talked about a lot on stage
just make sure no one has the same bit
yeah and and finding your voice is
something all comics
strive for is it when
went because 20 years in you know in 12
years seriously but
like when did you think or was there a
certain bit to where you felt like you
were starting to kind of
open up a new realm of your comedy and
into your voice
um well i feel like twitter helped me
out a whole bunch
because it was really a place to put
thoughts up and not care
like at first i didn't even understand
faves and retweets
um so i was just putting all kinds of
thoughts up on
twitter and not even in joke format and
then just realizing people
had similar situations like that then i
was then that made me realize
oh this is probably something i could
talk about so something so niche or
niche or whatever
you're like no a lot of people know what
you're talking about and you can do this
um sometimes on stage it won't hit but
there'll be an audience that likes it
and they'll find you
once you uh do that
uh but then the i think
i had one bit where i was i took the
train and this guy was like
i don't know the way he approached me
was so weird
and then i treated it as if it was a
real conversation and i felt like when i
did that on stage without doing a setup
punch line
and just doing bits as dialogue
and being just telling the story through
my point of view
i felt like that was the first time
where i was like i think now i get this
i know how to do this and that was like
a year in
when i moved to new york i felt more
like
there's a lot of time there's a lot of
times where i'm just like oh i think i
get
how to do this stand-up thing and then i
do a set and i'm like me okay maybe you
don't
but i felt like there is a time when
you're like oh
that's very that is definitely that's me
and i think i figured it my way of being
me on stage without trying really hard
and it felt effortless that's where that
i had a joke like that but i didn't do
it in my set
yeah yeah that is that is a good
note though of like you weren't going
for set up punch you were going for like
but what is sarah's point of view here
and that really started to
crack open that new writing yeah
well not that i would ever teach a class
but i think sometimes for classes like
or
just for comedy i think a lot of comics
when you first start out you're always
thinking about like i need to write a
joke i need to write a joke but
honestly like having you ever had that
guy at work or that friend that just
tells you their story of
what they did that morning and you're
laughing hysterically because they're
telling you
their what their problem solving skills
are
in their head or what they're thinking
and you're like that's so funny so
i remember a lot of times in like new
york i was like i'm not going to go up
and try to write a joke i'm just going
to
tell you about my day and then i felt
like that was more
satisfying than and then finding
bits that way then right trying to
figure out like what
set up punchline can i come up with now
yeah i definitely started like
one-liners first
and not way less conversational we just
had calcane on here and he
he mentioned the same thing where he
first like learned joke structure
and it's kind of like learning the rules
before you break them innocence
so it's like yeah but it's that's what
i've learned in interviewing over 200
comics
is like there's no one way it's like
everyone has their own unique way
at the end of the day yeah i feel like
like a good example of someone
that does that really well is naper
ghatsi like he doesn't really feel like
he's giving you a setup punchline all
he's really doing is telling you
what is going through his mind and
that's where the jokes come
and that's how how i feel like where you
find out
who you are on stage is like just talk
about the weird that's going
through your mind or your obsessive
thoughts and
i think people will relate to you or
find it interesting
i love it and this one actually comes
with people relating to you um
lee hudson he actually he's over in um
the uk so oh
he um i said that so like surprisingly
there's people over there
he uh listening yeah but yeah we do we
do a daily writing club in this facebook
group and he's
he's in here every day as well so oh
that's great
he um he asks do you and joe let each
other know
if one of you is going to do a joke
involving the other
um not necessarily
because we know what our boundaries are
and i don't think any one of us has done
something i know certain things to not
talk about because it's not my
truth or it's more that's joe's
ordeal that he's dealing with um
but i will try out stuff without telling
him and then if something works really
well that
involves him then i'm like well then
i want this in my set
so i'll let him know but we've never had
any
issues i think in the beginning i had a
joke about
i use my boyfriend as a prep premise but
it didn't involve
him but it's so much easier just to say
my boyfriend instead of being like two
boyfriends ago
[Laughter]
like no one cares and like it's just too
many words and so i just like
it's just easier for me to make it the
truth at that moment
and he was like but i didn't do that i'm
like yeah i know this is all jokes like
this isn't like a serious thing but he
got over that one
and i don't do it anymore because now
it's an old bit but did you have to
establish boundaries or did you have to
like cross the line to find it
have you had that discussion
no i don't think so i mean every now and
then like i think
joe has ocd and there's times where i
have it i find it very
annoying to deal with and i want to
write jokes about it but i
also don't want him to
feel like i hate him because of it
and so because sometimes that is the
thing that's weird about jokes they
they can come off mean
especially when they're not about if
they're not about you and you're joking
about somebody else like
i don't know it it can come off mean and
i don't
want him to think that i'm making fun of
him
so i try not to
and bob jorgensen asks can you tell us
about
your editing process how do you decide
when a joke
is edited properly
um well
i don't the thing is sometimes as i
was earlier i've i'll do a bit
and then i try to tag it over and over
or keep adding to it on stage and then
and then you will do it so much that you
can tell that the audience has lost
interest or you've lost them and then
that's how i was like okay
i'll stop it there or sometimes i'll if
i start going too dirty and i feel like
i'm getting groans i'm like okay
well that's not what i'm going for i'll
i'll tone it down a bit or take out a
line because i feel like that's
um too much but
um i usually i don't really edit i
usually just try to keep adding on
i always joke i write a premise i'll
write a joke and then i tag it three
years later because that can happen too
you bring you're like oh i haven't done
this joke in a while you do it on stage
and then all of a sudden because you
haven't done it for a while you thought
of a new thing about it and then you're
like wow
i just added to it now it's a new joke
again
and will you when it comes to editing
will you like record your set and then
like review it are you disciplined in
that practice
i try i'll listen to a set
i like i the reason why i record a set
is because sometimes you'll have this
happen you'll have a joke that's working
really really well
on a consistent basis for a while and
then all of a sudden
out of the blue it stopped working
so then i have to go back and listen to
when it was working
and figure out what i was doing
differently
to what i'm doing now
every now and then it's because you
dropped a phrase you just i naturally
drop stuff
and it's not because i do it on purpose
it just
happens you forget about it
and then that's why you got to listen
you got to go back and listen
yes the the work that people don't see
in comedy is that like writing
recording reviewing performing it's just
like people just think sometimes it's
just a magic trick
yeah no you're like yeah you're
constantly
i mean i'm always working on the wordage
on stage
i'm like okay that wasn't like i have a
bit
right now about throwing and it's not on
my album but it bothers me that it'll
work sometimes and it doesn't work now
or at all the time about the idea of
throwing trash into space and so i
always and like every time i try it i
always try to different angles with it
or pair it with another
bit or maybe use it as a like an
emphasis for another joke
or something how do you find
because i like a lot of people do try to
do edgier dirtier material
and you mentioned how sometimes you get
too many groans you have to dial it back
how do you find that sweet spot that
still makes like a a
dirty joke still like palatable
um well i always say say everything with
the smile
you'll get away with
um you'll get away with murder if you're
charming or with a positive attitude i
think
just think of like isn't it crazy
sometimes you could do it
two different people can do almost the
same kind of material but one is seen as
dirtier than the other
and i think a lot of the times it it is
on the delivery
or the your demeanor on stage or maybe
how you're dressed
or i mean there's so many factors but i
feel like
um yeah it's just like i think it just
depends on like
how you say it um but
i don't want to gross out anybody but
you can actually work with a grown
sometimes if you get a grown it causes
tension and then you can figure out a
line to release that tension with the
groan and then that
can make the the groan worth it
huh
you know sometimes like a crowd is like
oh and then
sometimes that feeling you're like well
i don't want them
i feel like i hit a nerve with them and
then you can take that
um tension and then you can use it to
your advantage
and either have equip to come off of
that or not
oh right and react to the groan almost
have a tag off of the groan
yeah it's a good it's a way to like you
know
turn the room around sometimes you could
make feels like you're about to lose
them
with a bit and you get a groan and i
feel like if you have that happen
you should kind of fig and you want to
still push through that bit you should
figure out a way to
use that groan to your advantage and
figure out a thing to say after
that to deflate the moment and then get
back into the bid again or something
but it's a great way to get one extra
laugh i think so you shouldn't really be
that
afraid of a groan you just don't want to
i don't like some people are like a
groan is just as good as a laugh and i
i'm like no it's not it doesn't feel as
good to me
yeah i i like it's a reaction though so
they're not
texting or tweeting so they're still
listening and invested
but yeah yes yeah but so
like that is true so if you have them
listening
just try to deflate it and that'll be a
great way to get an extra
laugh or you'll go go down another
tangent or something
oh that is gold well let's um
let's go ahead and get ready to land
this plane we do
we're um we're trying something
different here with you sarah this is
our first time trying this but we're
actually going to bring in
a member of the hot breath of verse here
she's a huge fan
she actually um we do a daily writing
contest
she just did a three-peat she just won
three days in a row
this past weekend and um she's listened
to her album like three times
she said and i just thought it'd be a
perfect opportunity just for
y'all to connect you know comic to comic
so um let's welcome
to the show here we have amanda her
facebook name is amanda oh
everyone so let's welcome let's see if
we can get her in here
amanda oh and then
let me pull up this other ah
did it work so intense oh my goodness
you're in a comedy club oh my god
i am i'm i'm in new york i'm at the
seller
i love that i just snuck in they had the
key under the mat
so cool well welcome um amanda please
like
ask away say hey whatever you want to do
this is your time
awesome hi sarah it's nice to meet you
yeah you too
um so i'm like a stand-up newbie
um but i listen to your album at least
like three times like
i just love it it's really really
awesome um and then i had a joke
like you talked a little bit about your
comedic voice how would you
personally describe your comedic voice
um i guess maybe a little dry or
irreverent i try not to i try to make
fun of
both sides or like keep it even the
darker stuff
a little bit on the lighter side not
like a lecturing thing
because i just don't have the chops for
that to be
like a strong opinion and then have to
defend it
because i feel like you have to know
your subject matter and i only read
headlines in a little bit of the article
so i try not to
but i i guess anecdotal are things that
um
throughout your day-to-day life where
you're like why is this making me feel
weird and then try to figure out why
and like or your obsessive thoughts or
any weird
thinking that you have i think that's
how you get your point of view across
awesome um and then
how do you go about joking about touchy
subjects like religion
or something like without offending most
people
i know i never want to offend too much i
mean some comics love to but
um and they're if they're they're really
good at it
uh i again like i try to
keep it like as simple as possible and i
also say like
i do think saying things with the smile
or letting the audience know that you're
like
dude we're just here to have fun and
this is like
if you can't joke about the serious
stuff then i mean it just makes life a
lot easier than i don't know what
to say to you you know like yeah
that's how i try to treat it like i try
in my mind
i try not to give it weight like just
act like it's like if you're talking
about um
a subject matter that's dark or heavy or
maybe very personal
just treat it as if it's another a joke
about
um you know day-to-day observations or
something like that
like you don't care just push through
and this is what you're talking about
and don't give
anybody the way to make you feel bad
about it
that's that's a good way to think about
it too because i've been thinking about
how to joke about things that are
like more that are personal but maybe
may come across as offensive like the
touchy subjects like religion and race
but i love that that you have like a
like like you said you say it with a
smile and you have like a positive
outlook so that maybe
people won't take it offensive right
because at the end of the day it is a
joke
you know yeah and you're like i'm just
trying to
i don't feel like my point of view is
right but this is how i feel about it
and i think this
is like this is the silly part about
like the religion or any darker side or
whatever like zeitgeist issue is
happening right now that's on the
serious side like
i mean there's so many funny things
about stuff that i feel like you should
be able to joke about it and it's your
it's your right especially if it's your
issue
yeah absolutely um and then i you were
talking a lot about your writing which
is really cool
um i just wanted to know what would you
say is your
writing process in general like do you
just
go based on inspiration or do you force
yourself to write all the time
well i'd like to say i would be one of
those guys that sit down and write for
hours and then they just produce
so much material that way but it doesn't
come to me that way
i don't think i've ever had a bit
organically work out or
come to me by just free writing i don't
it's not that i think that doesn't work
and i think that works for a lot of
comics and
there's a lot of great comics that
actually do that that produce a lot more
material than i do
but for me i don't know it's really
weird i
write more in the shower i write while
i'm doing dishes i love
doing um day to day stuff like errands i
it allows me i think your mind is more
relaxed because you're not worried about
important you're just
doing like mindless activities
um i tend to i think i have obsessive
thoughts so
it naturally comes to me to like think
of moments that
you know even years ago that bothered me
i'm like why is this bothering me and
then i think of a joke to make myself
feel
better about it like i had i remember
had that bit about
um i had to go to the hospital and it
was so annoying that i spent so much
money
for having colitis and then i was like
how funny that i just spent that was
like the most expensive diarrhea
ever and that pick came to me while
doing the dishes
like i was like oh collide yeah it was
just like
really expensive diarrhea um that cost
me like twenty thousand dollars and i
was like that's so
funny to me that that diarrhea costs
that much money
um and so though all those bits and then
like the
marie condo i was like why is it so
why is it gonna be so fascinated with
marie kondo and i'm like isn't it really
interesting
that she's an asian woman that came over
here and she's telling us to throw stuff
out even though in
uh culture in asia they make a lot of
the products that we buy that we consume
and i just thought it was so funny to
think of
like we all of the stuff that we're
buying is from asia
and then we have an asian lady being
like throw it out and i was like oh my
god what if the
i was doing the dishes and i was like
why is this why is that so weird and
then i was like it'd be weirder if an
american lady went over there and told
him to buy crap
like so i just put i flipped the script
on that one
and no like all of those came from like
driving but a lot of stuff just comes
from
um i find that i write when i'm hanging
out with friends and my mind is relaxed
and i'm having a really good time
and you like podcast you know you start
talking about like weird stuff on
podcasts like that's a great way for
mining material as well of
because you're sharing your thoughts and
then also when you're having a
conversation
um people ask you questions about this
incident that takes you down a road that
you probably wouldn't have even thought
about
if you were thinking about it on your
own so that's how i write and then when
i say i'll say something in a
conversation i'm like oh i like that
i'll put it on twitter to help me
remember it and then i'll see how it
goes and then if it does well i'll try
it on stage
that's cool that's good advice i feel
like the friends one at first i need to
have friends so
i'll do that no we'll start a podcast
[Laughter]
or hang out with other comics like all
my friends are comics so just
go to the mic you start meeting people
that think the same way and then uh
you you do just naturally shoot the
and you share your bits with people or
sometimes you'll do an open mic and then
somebody's like i really like that bit i
think
um that's got legs to it and then it's
something that you never even thought
about and then they tell you to do it on
stage and you do it and it works so like
just hang out at mics make you're just
naturally gonna make friends there
yeah definitely i'll start to do that um
and then my last thing was
do you have um like oh by the way i
the that marie condo bit is my favorite
one and i also love the asap
one that one i've been laughing about
for a while
um but do you have any like advice for
like a new new starting comic like what
is that one piece of advice you would
give to someone who's new and maybe even
like
especially women because i feel like
sometimes there's not really a lot of
women that are
on the scene yeah i mean we're not we're
not really coming through town
headlining so
you know there's only like i think it
seems like eight that
actually work the road on a consistent
basis so you're really not going to see
much so i just say like you form you
form your scene
just get your tight seven minutes in
whatever town that you're from and if
you're really enjoying it i think you
should
i say new york but you can do both
there's no right way i think
it's just like how much you want to make
make it work but i always say
um right just keep creating stuff
getting up on stage as much as you can
because that's where you're gonna do
most of your writing i think
is on stage and that's how you tighten
your set and then you'll just make
friends it'll make you feel more
comfortable
on stage because i felt like as soon as
i made
comedic uh friends that were comedians
then i felt better on stage because i
never really cared about what the crowd
thought i just wanted
comics to like me so that's a good
motivator and then i for me that worked
out really great is like
you know to get your voice seen really
you really should just be like creating
stuff and putting it online because
we're online like 24 7. it's like a
cocktail party
it's a great way for a lot of people
that wouldn't get to see you see you and
it's a
a good community i know a lot of people
hate twitter but i
if you learn to mute it and just treat
it as a joke machine
engage off of doing stuff like that or
writing sketches and putting videos up
like
that's such a great way for people to
see you
rather than like it's harder to go do
live stuff like
and get a huge audience base but you can
like
really find a community by like putting
your ideas
up on online i think
definitely yeah yeah especially i'm from
i'm from connecticut so there's not like
a lot around here um but the online
thing has been great that's why i love
hot breath and i love this community
because it's great to get that online
thing
[Laughter]
shout out thank you yeah like but a lot
of like uh relationships and jobs that
i've gotten
i i would say it's probably been more
because of
online content than it has been with
stage content you just want that way
when
you just want to work on stage because
you want to really get really good that
way when things start opening up for you
like opportunities you have a really
killer live set
and that you could start making money
and it'll just like
everything will just like meet up at the
right time and it'll just probably
explode so i say you work on both of
those avenues so they eventually like
meet up thank you
that's that's really helpful advice i
appreciate that yeah definitely
awesome oh that was so cool
yeah that's fun i mean i like i just
want things easier for everybody else
that started because i felt like
i had no idea what to do and then like
social media opened up and i thought
felt like it really opened the doors for
me
and so i i try to figure out ways that
are like faster and easier so you don't
waste your time
yeah that's what this whole this whole
show started as in this now online
community is it's like
me being 10 years in some people in the
community maybe have only done stand up
once but it's just like what did i wish
existed
when i started comedy and just trying to
give people the resources and
information to then go put it to work
you know
yeah i mean nowadays it's like it feels
like a lot more work but you can really
create your own avenue
and that you know if you don't really
get seen by industry you could probably
have a really great fan base and still
make a really great living doing this
and honestly if industry sees that
you're pulling in money
somebody's going to want to take
advantage of that so i just always say
keep creating for yourself and doing
that
you know doing stuff that you enjoy and
i think people will
like it's kind of like the law of
attraction that
people will come to you i love that
amanda was there anything else you had
for sarah
um real quick you mentioned new york i i
mean i'm from connecticut new york is
closer
is there a reason why you like you
prefer new york over la
i just think that
there is so much stage time here
and it's going to be frustrating it's a
lot of it feels really bad and you're
going to travel a lot but you can really
like
you can bomb an obscurity here without
industry really paying attention to you
where i think in l.a it sounds like a
industry a lot of industry can be in
some of these shows
that you're going to be on that might
you might go up a little too early and
it is weird it's like
if you don't do well they kind of
remember and that's it's
unfair to base you off of one set and i
feel like in new york
you can just experiment and kind of
figure out who you are
a little bit and be in the community
more
and i i just feel like you just got you
got to move to one of the bigger cities
because
i mean people are lazy they'd rather
just go look in their backyard for
talent than like go
around the country and figure it out and
then you're gonna get most of your work
from comics rather than industry and
it's
from them that's um hyping you up is
what's going to get you
work so i i say surround yourself with
talented people
gold well thank you amanda i'm so glad
we were able to do this
thanks for asking great questions people
are cheering you on
a lot of people saying yeah amanda and
giving you applause
yeah moved to new york but and things
are opening up we have a lot of outdoor
shows now so
oh really and rent's probably going to
be coming down so i say take advantage
in the next few months if we have our
together with the pandemic
yeah good i'll see i'll see i would love
to new york is awesome
thank you so much for for answering
questions and chatting thank you joel
yeah absolutely amanda yeah yeah thanks
for hanging out
all right let's get back
we're going to land this plane here now
okay
she's uh
zoom zoom exits are always awkward oh i
know
i try to haul the smile the whole time
yeah this this is our first time
experimenting with that so that was
i'd say a great success yeah it's fun
so um just in in closing here do you um
well first where can people
get your albums support your album and
any anything else you have going on as
well
um you you can get it anywhere it's on
all like the
you know it's on pandora spotify itunes
amazon play google play or all that
stuff
um you can get it there and then i'm
always wanting my instagram to build so
follow me
at stalmosh or twitter it's the same
handle
s-t-o-l-l
awesome and you're yeah we'll be sure to
link to
um because you have a great link that
links to all the different places you
can get the album we'll be sure to share
that in the description of this episode
because it's what was interesting is you
you talked about
uh the label approaching you and you
said 800 pound but is that connected
with laugh button are they like kind of
one and the same now
yeah i think they're one in the same oh
okay yeah cause i saw it was on laugh
button records
so are they when you go with a record
versus independent
like is it uh because it debuted at
number one on itunes and like all these
these great things like what it what is
like the perk of like a label verse
uh independent um
well so the per for doing independent
you get you don't have to do any you
don't have to pay for advance but
there's probably some money that's going
to come out of your pocket but
it'll be under your control um
the thing that i liked about 800 pound
gorilla is or
laugh button is that they're they're
they did they'll do research on you like
dude they look at your analytics they're
like
instagram and that stuff and see where
your demographic is
um and then they know and when they
listen to your album and all that stuff
they kind of know what like serious
playlists that you can get on or what
pandora stations that would be good for
you
that would um more peop that would
you would hit hard and then people would
share or like and so they're good with
algorithms and doing the market research
and like
promoting and doing all that hard stuff
for you that i think if you did it on
your own
you know like you could probably put it
out but it might not hit as strong or
make
any income but it'll just be something
that'll feel good for yourself
uh yeah so that number one debuting at
number one which
uh bob asked do you now have a blood
feud with weird al
since you knocked him out of first place
well i knew i wasn't gonna last at
number one that long
first of all it's like um jim gaffigan
dominates he's and i know he's got like
albums and they're all in the top 10 or
20.
um and you know what's really weird so i
did research and i'm not saying i don't
know
but there's only three women about in
the top 200
and two are is two belong to kathleen
madigan
so it's just like really interesting for
some reason it feels like there's not a
lot of female comics
on the album circuit or maybe people
don't like to hear our voices
i don't know i'm like what's happening
there
but that is something that i noticed um
so i knew i knew i wasn't going to last
on there that long but when you
set it up as a pre-order like when you
you go with the record label
it helps you jump to number one which
helps you get pushed up at the
algorithms and
like sell it easier and all that stuff
ah so set it up as a pre-order so then
when it's released
it like surges and you can get higher
ranks
i from some reason we i was talking
about with some other comics i think in
order to get
like number one you only have to sell
like 60 copies that day
so if you just sell slightly more than
jim gaff again that day you will hit
number one
for about 10 minutes and then he'll
knock you off
but you could forever say number one
itunes
album you know yeah for sure
awesome awesome you just want you just
wanted that screenshot and then you can
post it up and then your friends from
high school think
you're great oh look they're doing it
look yeah that dream did come true
yeah awesome yeah well people yeah
people really appreciate you doing this
and um a lot of people thinking and
yeah this this has been amazing sarah
thank you so much for taking the time
to share all such valuable information
um of course
yeah definitely comics you should
definitely go
get sarah's album it's absolutely
hilarious
and you'll add a lot of context to the
things we got to talk about today
so go forth and your podcast as well
go listen to your podcast right yeah vag
podcast with
adrian apollucci beautiful awesome
well um is there any closing comedy
advice anything
you've gathered over your years of
experience that you have found most
helpful that you could in
close us with here um well
lately so sometimes i feel like um
if you have goals like i want to be on
snl
or i want to be a late night writer or
something like that
i think those are goals that are like
maybe a little bit beyond your control
and it might not work out that way so i
think
what you should your goal should be more
um based in instead of like what is
something that you can do that can get
you to snl
or what is something that you can do
that can get you to late night
is focus on that goal rather than that
end goal so
be like i'm going to write five new
characters
and i'm going to put them online that is
my goal for this year or i'm going to
write a joke
every day or every hour about what's
going on in the news because i feel like
that'll make you feel better you've hit
your goal that is something that you can
control
and then i guarantee you the other stuff
will happen
and you will get work that way rather
than being like
focusing on the prize you should focus
on the work
um amen could not have said it better
focus on
it'll make you happier yeah were you
wanting to get on snl and then something
you had to like
move on from yeah i did i wanted i
wanted i
i felt like i got close one year i
submitted a packet
and then now it's like my sixth year of
submitting and i feel like it's not
happening
so i was like um instead of being upset
about not getting that and that happens
and it's a very hard goal to make
um and it doesn't say anything less
about your
skill set um so what i decided instead
of doing that i decided i'm going to
make a sketch
for my own instagram at least once a
month so i started my own film festival
to give me a deadline
and i feel like that's made me feel
better
because like even when you write a
packet so you didn't make it
so why are you just sitting on these
sketches that never got made like you
should go out and create stuff for your
own
instagram and then people will see it
and then you can
like live off those likes and shares at
least from that and that'll make you
feel better
who knows i mean we just had sam jay on
here and she had never written a sketch
and now she's a writer in snl like i
don't know what the rhyme or reason
to anything out of our control it
is it's like you know you could be the
it person for
industry or that time or you had a rock
and set at montreal and they just give
you the job and then other people are
like
grinding writing sketches all the time
and then you're just
you're never making anything you're just
creating packets for these like
conglomerates that don't make it free so
why are you writing stuff for other
people
you should write stuff for yourself boom
because at least you can get that made
i love it focus on the work and not the
prize i love that
awesome yeah people are saying they're
gonna go check out dina
on your uh podcast a lot of people
commented about that
oh dina hashem she's great she's a great
joke writer as well
very nice well i love this you're a
great joke writer as well
and you're thank you so much that we
learned a lot today so we really
appreciate your time
of course i love talking comedy i like
nerding out
that's that's this whole show that's
this whole show just nerding
out about comedy um we we had joe on a
few years ago
when um he was here in atlanta for the
red clay festival so
when his special comes out we'll
definitely circle back with him
yeah but uh yeah it comes out this
thursday
yeah on comedy on youtube on comedy
central
uh youtube channel 9pm est
oh snap yeah well then yeah definitely
go check out joe special yeah
well then we'll yeah we'll follow up
with him about that i didn't realize it
was that soon but all right
yeah very nice well thank you for doing
this sarah this has been absolutely
amazing go listen
go get sarah's album everyone if you're
serious about becoming a comedian
join our facebook group linked in the
description below to start getting tips
like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing
today